hello and welcome to the new world
review I am grand line waifu and i have
a proposition for you we have a lot to
get through so let's take a moment or
two to appreciate a few of the crew on
the journey with you you know i really
didn't mean to rhyme all that and i'm
not really sure where i was going with
it in hindsight so i think they deserve
some thumbs up for it up or down is your
choice there's also a subscribe button
somewhere click it i said click it okay
let's go
episode 46 46 yes episode 46 this entire
episode was a setup for the next one and
while i'm not upset about that it meant
that i struggled with this one because
functionally it felt as though not a
great deal happened now don't get me
wrong or throw your computers or TV
across the room don't rip off your
beanie a lot did happen but it was all
cerebral it was all through experiments
and questions being raised for the
future which is great we want that set
up we want to have the questions because
by the time we get there we want to know
what all the hubbub is about and we also
want to know what the stakes are finally
reaching a point for example where the
three I'm going to say underachievers at
this point though I think it's more that
karateka is an overachiever that 3
reaching a point where they've realized
they haven't seen could up OK yet the
fact that they had no idea of current
events as an auction they planned on
getting into the fact that they decided
to spend their money on something that
was an incredible longshot well gone
killa and lay audio how do you get
anything done without korabik ah
speaking of karateka will he make a deal
with Hisoka
can we take a moment because i didn't
last episode 2 note how beautiful the
image of his Sokka sitting on that
merry-go-round was the idea that he
specifically called Karaka to this spot
probably because he wanted to look good
in that particular location is very
Hisoka
and let's discuss this deal briefly what
is it Hisoka 1 to be given access to
what karappa Cano's while causing more
chaos than he has to now he wants to
swing in the direction of the leader of
the phantom troupe would that make him
the leader of the phantom troupe I can
very much see a situation in which
karateka manages to beat Volgin and gets
into the Phantom troupe while also
getting into the good books of the boss
he's currently being paid by I'm seeing
a lot of double triple maybe quadruple
crossing happening and actually I find
that deliciously entertaining because we
get to wonder when it will all come
crashing down assuming he doesn't
immediately die in the next episode the
fact that karateka is thinking about it
now rather than making an immediate
decision suggests he still has his eye
on the prize
rage hasn't consumed him regardless of
what that heavy metal theme he has
is Caracas seems to be playing both the
long game and oddly the short game he's
specifically going for his goals and it
seems to be a methodical situation the
idea that melody is there at first gave
me some comfort but now I wonder that
she's either enabling him deliberately
or mistakenly either way there are
serious concerns about how things are
going to turn out between them
especially if he's learning from her how
to keep calm but still do the thing
being in charge of the group he was
originally a flunky for is a huge step
up and the fact that melody helped with
it says a lot why is she putting so much
faith in him
is she what's going on there since she
felt rage in him to begin with she's
been following him around and doing her
best to support him why it's not that I
sense huge ulterior motives in her she's
the purest person in the show since a
little Zushi but it feels either super
misguided or super planned and I can't
figure out which why did she put him
forward as the best person to lead the
group yes in this context he is the best
person to lead the group but we don't
even know anything about silent guy in
the black and white suit we don't know
about the others frankly I'd have put
melody in charge she's trying to get to
the same place as karateka then again I
suppose if it came to it Melody's
probably afraid that karateka will kill
anyone to get to the top so if she
clears the path a bit he'll get to the
top and she can follow in his weight
much safer quite clever we'll go with
that
okay neon I'll bite why the mummy why is
the mummy so important to you what is it
about a mummy that's causing her such
distress and what's going to happen when
she acquires a mummy is it her mummy
maybe it's her mummy whoa what a strange
kid daddy nah start respecting her
wishes it's a great situation but at the
moment shouldn't the focus be on keeping
her safe does disrespecting exactly what
she wants affect her ability to see the
future jumping around a bit because the
episode jumped around a bit so more
members of the Phantom trooper Hunters
not all of them or even a lot of them
but one at least the creepy big eyed one
who looks kind of like Mellie owed us
from the 7 deadly sins
the relationship between these
characters is fascinating to me they
help each other out they care about each
other who go of in giving old mate a
kiss on the cheek was really sweet
reminding each other not to get careless
was done in a way to show affection
between the characters and I really
appreciated that as a way to see how the
characters interact it suggests they've
been together for a long time and had
time to build those relationships either
that or they hate each other with a
passion and they're keeping their
enemies close hang on he wasn't in this
episode but what happened to piggy is he
gonna turn up soon there are so many
hang
parts in this series right now that I
hope are resolved just I just hope
they're resolved at full stop it's an
effect that has been deliberately pushed
for and I get that but I do wonder still
how it will all come together for now
the music followed by silences karappa
Cohen / faceoff was delicious and
allowed for kerothic as hardcore
Throwdown to be received as fully as it
needed to be I want to get to the next
episode so let's do exactly that
candy break food candy okay so we had a
lot of setup for this episode but only
one aspect of episode 46 actually came
to a conclusion here you go VIN it was
nice knowing you actually you know what
it really wasn't you were an awful
person
apart from that time you kissed your
friend on the cheek before deciding to
run off and fight a kid also you have
leech eggs in your pee oh the leech eggs
that's disgusting
did we need to see that a leech egg
small enough to come out of male
genitalia no let's frame this another
way
well the number of eggs that came out
and with their size how big must his
genitals actually be too big to use it
okay leech eggs
I just moving on it pleases me that they
actually went to a deserted wasteland
the idea that they would have had to
travel together did they go in silence
did they chat did they stare each other
down the entire time I would do some
pretty extreme things to have someone
create art of them on a train or in a
car and posturing over who would drive
that I would like to see that please the
Blood Moon was a really nice touch but
it makes me wonder whether that's
actually a curta thing or related to
Qatar in any way
I doubt it but I'm not sure and it's
going to bug me it's okay Liam can tell
you all whether it is or not right now
and I don't get to find out so great
karappa Cohoes a full new outfit I love
that he has a style and he fully commits
to it not only that he looks shrank
between hisoka's Schwing and Caracas
stripping style Schwank I'm impressed at
the forward momentum of this series when
it comes to artistic choices speaking of
artistic choices the art in this episode
was phenomenal from start to finish
there was a gleam to cut-up occur that
transcended what Evo was doing you could
see in the art that core applica was
going to win the movement in his hair
the way the scene was lit Hoover didn't
look as menacing there were moments of
beauty where I was fooled into thinking
that this was a closer fight than it
seems to have been but the colors
involved the depth that made things like
Govans eyes pop as he realized how much
in danger he actually was there was some
really beautiful art but Shawn the
overall movement of the characters was
great the art of seeing them go all out
despite or maybe because of the Super
Saiyan lists of Vosges men usage we just
didn't see that over there new search
with Korra pika perhaps showing that
isn't in an energy it was focused rather
than overstated and that he was using in
I suppose the entire time to conceal his
intention and the beautiful lack of
color in anything but corrupt because
eyes and the moon oh that death was
beautiful like it was just artistically
beautiful karateka guiding his opponent
was a big moment for me in a big moment
for Qatar Bakr the fact that he wanted
to test ovo strength the extent of it to
see how well he could control and handle
the situation showed just how confident
he felt about it
well maybe not confident about winning
but confident about his convictions he
tracked down his prey he caught his prey
and he killed his prey after learning
all he could about the others he would
hunt then he buried him he gave over
more respect I think the new Vogon gave
any one of his kills and that's how we
remember that kora because the good guy
he's trying to dispose of evil but he's
also not willing to sacrifice his
humanity or hurt earnest to do that the
music of this episode was wonderful it
was a combo of the music used in the
past and built on to give a sense of the
familiar but new stronger give me the
best you've got was very much the theme
here and here in Caracas musical theme
layered on top of the original theme for
fights used in the arena and back in the
hunter exam was great we got a sense of
growth from him in the way that we
really haven't from any of our other
Pataki
for a while I rarely actually discussed
the note-taking process I have four
episodes I watch them right notes
because I can touch time so I can type
what I'm thinking without losing the
thread of what I'm watching my note for
the next topic of conversation is as
follow took out his contacts let's see
who is stronger scarlet eyes become
specialist oh that's scary input her
time yes that is how I write notes their
epoch can link to how epic a moment is
this was a beautiful important moment
and while I want to go into my notes
more I feel like they might have covered
everything well he took out his contact
so we got to see his eyes blazing then
we found out that he was a specialist
and who boy it was all over we've been
hearing talk of specialists this whole
time the idea that when he gets angry
when he's emotion becomes engaged he's a
specialist it's a great use of all those
mechanics set up months ago those
conditions the rules the spiders what
happens when they're all dead I mean
beyond literally everyone else coming
after him because he's now got a bounty
on his head like the one piece crew the
planning all of it he doesn't seem to
have a plan for the long run but beyond
killing them all would he have to come
up with a new weapon if he decides to
attack anyone else for whatever reason
he won't ever have a grudge like this
one so he becomes less powerful as soon
as his goal is completed this was a dark
episode the amount of blood the explicit
calling out of how sick the entire
situation made Korra pika
a gentle character driven to revenge and
the use of torture again given the
levity in which the series began it
seems to have escalated pretty quickly I
maintain that this is darker than
anything that happened during the exam
no matter what you or Liam think I
didn't raise an eyebrow and characters
were being eaten or people were getting
their heads chopped off because we
didn't see the extent of the gore we
didn't experience the psychological
impact it caused both to the victim and
to the character inflicting here we got
all of it in detail and that's what
makes this darker than the first or
second arcs thus far despite that
something that could have made it darker
and got cut up occur the knowledge he
wanted was missed and I wonder if it was
deliberate harappa kot could have put
the condition on her Govans heart that
the second he told karateka what he
wanted to know it would kill him I know
it would have put her out became the
position of having to wait him out but
it may have paid off in the long run I
don't know it felt odd that he went that
way as an intelligent character maybe it
was literally because of the extent of
the strain and that says a lot actually
I don't feel like it was a wrong move I
don't
think it was a wrong thing to happen I
just feel like going about it the
opposite direction was my instinct on
that it was also a remarkably similar
power to haiku guy so it was really nice
to see that come back into play and I
wonder when he learned how to do that I
wonder whether cutter Packer will
contact Lee audio gone and Kilwa there's
a point he's hitting where he actually
could just have his own spin-off series
where we go to him for the drama then
follow the others for comic relief the
fact that he called melody and stuck
with the job as a priority shows where
his mind is at and maybe it's good for
him to keep his distance since krolow
actively wants him dead - now I must say
I am loving this arc I'm enjoying the
thrill of it the intensity and many
other things but I'm really hungry so
that's it from me because I need to find
food if you enjoyed this continue the
conversation in the comments and on the
discord server click here here or here
or here or something like what you like
dislike what you don't and don't tell me
don't let me - hmm is that me telling
you secretly what to do who knows I
don't feed me